just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one podcast
in the
[Music]
world all right this is a this is a fun
one you know what I mean yeah we'll see
about that Air
Asia oh yeah yeah yeah I know Air Asia
their seats are so small are they pretty
good are they Chinese they're Asian I uh
I mean dude we we we took it to go to
Malaysia oh so they're Chinese what do
you mean dude I I don't know if they're
Chinese they might be Malaysian or
whatever was it a good flight it wasn't
a good flight why no you're thinking of
Asiana I think but Asiana is Korean yeah
that's Korean no no yeah Air Asia is
scary dude why is it scary is it Chinese
dude when you [__] see
pilots and it's like their uniforms are
like this oh no way and their hats like
on the side that's hella swag and they
look like they just drank at the at the
airport bar [__] Soy saw stains and
[__] no but but they're the best Pilots
not our flight oh oh because they're
like they just take some cocaine like
Denzel and they flip the plane wait why
why why are they the best because
they're probably like in the war you
know and then so they're like really
[__] up but then they could still
operate the oh they just [__] drank
[__] ton of whiskey in the bathroom
and now they're going like oh get go fly
their seats are small they have soul
planes for I feel like it's for children
wow oh no so their boss it feels like a
school bus for kids Tony Fernandez what
yeah Fernandez Fernandez right what if
he's Filipino maybe he's been slammed
after posting a picture of himself
receiving a massage during a meeting on
social media oh I saw this [__] it's
hilarious but he's like doing a meeting
bro that's Fernandez no but he he's
going through a what is that thing
menopause he's going through he's having
hot
flashes he has to take off his shirt
guys don't do menopause no guys have it
too they're not required to guys have it
too we do yeah like going through did he
write anything in the captions like no
not the OV one but the guy one what's
the guy one like the metop PA but forgot
what happens it's a feeling you just
know it's happening what what's male
menopause explain it I don't know I'm
not on game please put me on game if you
Google um do men have menopause Google
would tell you yes they do have you
searched this before no they'll say no
yeah what yeah okay I I Googled do men
have menopause the first thing I popped
up is debunking the male menopause myth
okay what's the source I Google it and
it just shows Robin Williams saying [__]
no yeah see okay there is none I thought
there was one it says this is known as
menopause in men production of t
testosterone and other hormones declines
over a period of many years and the
consequences aren't necessarily clear
event it's not a singular event it just
slowly declines after you're 24 little
by little but sometimes they drop heavy
it depend on the person Sperma drop oh
that's true Fernandez it dropped that
day the
quotum so he's going through it you can
clearly see it that day appointment on
the day that it was going to drop to
massage the testosterone back in yeah be
sensitive to
that come on
I want a testosterone massage yeah he
sharing he was sharing the story on uh
on LinkedIn he seemed to be saying that
the fact that he could get a half naked
massage during a meeting was indicative
of the great culture in the Air Asia
workplace wait culture wait is he is he
like trying to do one of those like hash
Hustle Life things where it's like yo
man I'm still doing my meetings grinding
out but I still get a massage cuz health
first he said the Greek they better have
a bombass stroll when they walk in the
office imagine if they showed the
boardroom table and it was like a oval
table and all 10 of the exacts were all
shirtless with massages that's [__]
tight actually that's cool yeah it was
but he's the only one enjoying it did
everyone's butt ass nak it who ratted on
him that's kind of messed up he ratted
on himself he said he said got to love
Indonesia and Air Asia culture that I
can have a massage and do a management
meeting oh this fo was like flexing it
wow so what are people saying that's cuz
that's literally like what JK used to do
all the time kind of what about body
positivity yeah we would have body
positiv no one said anything about his
body call Fat you're the first person
that called him fat no no no no no you
would no no I'm saying that like open
body are you indirectly fit shaming yeah
no no I'm just saying like what's wrong
with like
[Laughter]
wrong you can do it back man
bro it hurts when you doing Jason you
got to get him back before the video
ends you got to get him oh you don't got
much time man yeah dude the the clock is
ticking dude oh [__] he's he's stalling
you oh my God this is
unprecedented w war people's responses
like put keep put your shirt back on you
fat [__] is that what people say that's
the highest like comment good work ethic
and culture not flaunting his body and
privilege oh but maybe that wasn't his
attention oh see flaunting his body
they're jealous these are all jealous
haters jealous haters they're like how
dare you show your sexy body some CEOs
need to stay off
LinkedIn bro if that was your CEO in a
company meeting would you be like this
guy's Fu no but like to be fair he is he
is saying that like culturally cuz he's
talking about Indonesia right yeah what
is he in culturally like if if you're
like in another country and that's the
culture to do that during a meeting it's
not going to be up for Global scrutiny
that's just yeah it's culturally some
countries cut off the clips I'm question
you guys though cuz you guys you guys
are in like board meeting CEO some take
off the shirt and and do the meeting
what's the problem yeah some cultures
you get a [__] [__] while you're
in the meeting
exactly if you guys were in a like a
like a meeting like that and your CEO of
the company that you work with started
getting a massage with the shirt off
would you feel weird no I'd be like
would you not give a [__] can I get next
please I think it depends on the
industry dep on indry yeah if it's a sex
industry of course it's normal that's
that's actually more like what if no
what if what if you guys worked on
airliner in a [__] barbell Brigade
meeting I don't think that actually
would be weird I just think this is an
interesting group to ask when like the
two like guys here are constantly
shirtless what I'm wearing a careful
boys t-shirt that you can get with the
description below oh [__] nothing but
plugs no but like seriously what would
you would that be weird
um I mean we've been in a bunch of
Hollywood meetings where people are
[__] weird and I'm like oh that's
just kind of like entertainment it's
normal people have weird personalities
what kind of
Weir just like people with funny
haircuts and [__] like what's a funny
haircut dude I don't know like a 50
50-year-old trying to look 20 or
something I don't know just like weird
super high flat top I mean getting a
massager your meeting doesn't seem that
weird right what about if you post about
it does that is that does that I think
that's when you're asking for it like
you can't post to the general everywhere
okay what if he gets a massage naked and
he licked his fingers and touches nipple
twice is that too much he better be in
Indonesia then we know he's funny then
we know he's cool okay yeah he's got a
sense of humor yeah this guy's chill I
guess yeah run your company your way but
if you post about it you make it a
public exactly put it on a public form
like it's not a problem to the people in
the room stop showing off your sexy body
feel like I feel like a lot of people
just ha hate like the perception of rich
people you know a CEO absolutely they
just have a distaste for it you know so
no matter what this guy's intention is
people are going to take it as like
always he's rubbing in our faces so so
you think rich people um is their life
is equivalent as poor people what do you
mean like um if somebody is like a
millionaire billionaire is their life
just as good as like a poor person life
no cuz they're lonely I think it really
depends on but I think the I think it's
relative in the way that if like even
for you Jason like if you just posted
yourself with a a martini on the beach
and you just said living the good life
some of your friends won't even like
that how much more for the world you
know yeah that's so true homies will be
hating
some so then you see I can't wait to
flex on
everybody I'll do the same thing I'll do
it even crazy and and I if everyone
talks [__] to me I'll be like [__] you
wish you had my life but that's but I
feel like that's you guys's Mo though
like that just like if I see you doing
like hey I'm having the best life at the
thing I'll be like oh that's what Joe
does if you didn't do that he'd think
something's wrong yeah I'm like what do
you mean yeah that's true cuz I I would
be at the Rio yeah overlooking the strip
from the backside and then being like
don't you wish you had my life yeah cuz
you're like you're you're travel guy
you're [__] I'm like okay so like
people
normal
people I would say that they probably
don't look at me they look at other
travel vloggers I'm targeting the
Walmart audience so people that shop at
Walmart looks at me and goes man that
guy's got it you know cuz hell yeah I'm
the guy that goes to Costco and then you
know when you first step into Costco you
got the like the iPad and you got like
the [__] most expensive like
Listerine packs and then like you got
the big [__] right that's what I get so
the Costco people are looking at me like
yo one day I want to be like him cuz I
want to get the couch that he got cuz
they're just shopping at Costco getting
the other items they're not getting the
top yeah the Hermes people's not looking
at me yeah yeah I feel you yeah I'm like
the top of Ross the top of Costco you
know Costco and Ross are pretty
different like Joe could take us all to
a Ross right now and he would be like
buy whatever you guys want n no store
I'll take the ra okay may but we would
politely only take one or two things
right that's true I'll buy a neck tie
for $2 and yeah exactly I'll get a pair
of socks for 10 you know what I mean and
then Joe be like I got it easy no
problem that's that's the type of Rich
he is I'm the like I'll be like Yo dude
let's go to Texas Roadhouse unlimited
[__] bread rolls on me but isn't it
unlimited for you already or no you
don't know that cuz you never been there
it's too ball don't [__] spoil it
Jason I'm sorry I don't I'm just asking
the gesture take the gesture said you
get unlimited cards say thank you thank
you so much sir thank you and then you
don't order a drink you just order ice
water okay everybody come with me to um
wrong
[Music]
two